(crunching)
(whooshing, squeaking)
(jazzy music)
- We have rice,
there's salmon,
and then there's like
onions and, I think, mango.
It smells like sushi and
it looks like a taco.
- Have you ever seen
anything more beautiful?
It's a taco combined with
sushi, two of my favorite foods.
And then this is like a
crunchy tempura seaweed.
- I think anything shaped
like a taco is a win.
(crunching)
- Mmm
It kind of tastes like
something with tempura on it.
- I like it a lot.
So many different textures, flavors.
Crunchy, soft.
- I think it could use more
of a vegetable element.
Like, in the cross-section
it's pretty much just raw fish
and then rice underneath,
so it's kind of soft on soft.
I wish there was like raw cucumber
or like an avocado layer
or something like that.
(crunching)
- I feel like there could be more flavor.
They're slightly bland.
I do like bland foods, though.
(crunching, laughing)
- I like the crunch.
The rice is just like filler,
fish tastes fresh, I love mangoes.
- I don't like mangoes, but I
liked it which is interesting.
- You don't like mangoes?
What's wrong with you?
- I don't really like mangoes.
I don't know.
- It really just feels like raw fish
inside something crunchy.
- Wow!
You would not think that
this would work out.
It's like super crispy,
and like I love seaweed,
and there's rice and I love rice.
- The tempura seaweed as
a shell, stroke of genius.
This is a symphony of flavor.
Follow-up question, where do I get this?
Who makes this?
- I don't even know if you
could consider it sushi,
but it's like a sushi-inspired taco.
It has a really good flavor, though.
I really like it.
- It's good, I would
eat this again for sure.
- Can we keep this?
- 10 out of 10 would eat again.
- You wanna try it?
Mmm.
Yes, camera, eat the taco.
(jazzy music)
(whooshing, squeaking)